hey guys I'm Jess he was another episode
of games Whitney's top 50 we have a
brand-new host Andy McCune thanks for
coming thanks for having actually you're
a permanent hurts to look forward to
seeing him more okay so you just moved
to Australia what's your favorite things
over the weather absolutely when I left
them in and we had about a foot and a
half of snow so this is a lot lot better
yes it is that's why we're in the pock
and it's not raining this week you're
his news any do you like Starcraft how
about starcraft soccer i'm just great
apparently a lot of people love stock up
because they're remastering it which is
pretty exciting it's gonna be HD it's
getting full case abort their fixing the
audio and i've had a lot of people
saying there looks to be similar to the
original but that was kind of the whole
point because they wanted to make it so
it was really similar to what veteran
players expected soccer 4k support to
cloud save classic matchmaking they're
introducing as well which is gonna be
really great not only are they updating
the original starcraft and fruit wolf
they're having a free updates to the
original so you can play that for free
now the starcraft anthology it's free so
if you missed out on what was a pretty
defining RTS and now's the you know a
good time to jump back yeah and they've
had things like observe and Murr there's
new key binding options and stuff like
that so you can like customize the
experience and just get back into the
classic I beg usurped Eddie you're here
to talk about shooters yeah that wasn't
anything that was another thing my thing
now no tell me all about what's
happening cold Judy so big rumors this
week unsubstantiated for now but very
interesting all the same youtube channel
had some leaked promotional images for a
new collar duty game supposedly called
just simply World War two as the name
suggests will be set in World War two
allegedly in development at advanced
warfare studio sledgehammer games
infinite warfare kind of you know
underperformed from sales perspective
and during an earnings call last year
they talked about how our management
talked about how this year's game would
go back to roots and so that's a
suggestion already that is going to be
in World War two and like I said every
game up until modern warfare was set in
world war one so or World War two so
it'll be exciting if that does come to
fruition for sure Jessica tell me what's
happening in the world of south-asian
dumplings Oh dan I think you've
accidentally thought we're talking about
momo's a little
please when we're actually talking about
mmos one in particular world of warcraft
so while the warcraft is just honey 7.2
update cold tomb of surrogate surrogate
sagar asst the update adds a new dungeon
pvp brawls the pet battle dungeon which
i thought was the pet battle dragon
originally when i wrote this it's not
but that would be cool that would be a
sweet drag mm-hmm also class specific
campaigns which lead to quest that
unlock new epic class mounts 7.8 also
adds the ability to fly so you don't
have to trek around like a goddamn plan
that's fun but first you need to get the
broken Isles achievement which is
actually really hard to get in super
annoying but worth it cuz let's black
how do you get the broken altitude
honestly it's like an 18 step process
there's actually part 2 of the
achievement able to get your first you
got to get part 1 then you got to get
part two you can also enhance your
artifact with new empowered traits high
ranks for existing traits and there's a
new final trait that's unlocked through
a quest line so much to do there's so
much to do basically it'll keep you busy
till the next expansion and you're a
real lover of satchels and messenger
bags cracks I really guess you know you
don't love carrying [ __ ] well guess what
when we pre order the Destiny to
collectors edition you can get a sweet
carrier bag sweet it really is dead let
me tell you all about it so if once you
came out and have confirmed that destiny
2 is coming out on sep tember 8 and it
is coming to pc ps4 and xbox one however
pc i know unfortunately though you're
not taking your guns your abilities or
really anything that matters just the
way your guardian about my gala horn
sorry made all those gala horns there in
the bin because you won't know why the
red Legion have come to the tower and
they've blown that [ __ ] our way so I
think what funds you're saying is you're
going to have to go to unexplored parts
of our solar system to collect your gear
collect your Guardians get new abilities
take the fight back to the last City
retake it from underneath the travelers
might I assume that's at the bottom of
that experience and apparently be heaps
of loot and speaking of blue so many
collectors editions this time so there's
the vanilla edition you've got the
digital deluxe edition which gives you
the expansion pass with two expansions
and then there's the collector's edition
which comes with a satchel back a
dimension that has a USB charger and if
it's powered by the Sun because the
Cabal of solar enemies because it's
really clever and you get a space
blanket to get all kinds of stuff
out of that can't wait dan I know you
like collectibles I love them do you
like Funko pops no I hate you know what
I do like that you show me blizzards new
line of collectibles also does it have
previously made these awesome statues of
ever watching the world warcraft
characters but now they're introducing a
new line that they calling Blizzard
collectibles and they're going to focus
on making premium products for hardcore
collectible fans oh my desk is already
full of [ __ ] so let's get somewhere so
first up they have three overwatch
tattoos a tracer or Reaper and a widow
makeup which all about one hundred fifty
dollars each and they're about 13 inch
high either all hand-painted look pretty
cool they also have all the walk up
statues with like Illidan and the orc
guys mr. Hellscream yeah there is
slightly more price here they're $350
they also have what could be the coolest
thing it's like a half stone keepsake
chest what that is basically the box
that half stone opens in when the game
starts ah and it makes a theme song when
you open it up yeah it's important like
that does it have said they're going to
be interesting more premium things later
on in the year I can't wait I seem to
not be able to wait for everything
you're just so excited about him I love
it you're so excited show me your money
go run around that's games what news top
five for this week I'm Dan and I'm Eddie
ah perfect and because Jessica tempted
the gods and said we had perfect weather
it's about to start raining again and
i'm off to Hawaii so quit stalin stalin
we've got something to do one in
particular world of warcraft world of
warcraft where we talk about our fit
what i do that why did i do that but
everything that was perfect except you
said
so having us an inning guy really yeah
that's not an Australian thing today